Transcriber: Bushra Tughar
المدقّق: Shimaa Nabil
?What do you have in Saudi Arabia
you only have women who wear black clothes
,men who wear white, sands
.mountains, desert and petrol
Unfortunately, this is the stereotype
image of us in the West, they know nothing
about the culture or
.the history of the Kingdom
Scholarship is a life journey
.not just a certificate
It is a cultural communication
among civilizations
.in our society or in our environment
The communication began
through literary salons
.which included Arab people
Such us London’s literal
and cultural salon
in which we worked
on cultural communication
.poetry, culture and literature
Most of those present at the salon
are immigrant writers
Saudi visitors who like to know
the Kingdom’s culture or Arabic poets
We also have contribution
out of kingdom’s borders in Mai’s salon
which was interested in culture
but out of mother tongue
there was a cultural communication among
people of different
.nationalities and cultures
This communication was so good but
.it needs to be on a lager group of people
Most attendees were of people interested
,in literature and culture
they were minorities
not more than 20 persons
we considered the type of modern cultural
communication we need to reach more people
we started with the cultural attached
.with a movement without words
The movement was about artwork at
the first imitative of scientific society
It was affiliated with
,the Saudi attaché
we started organizing exhibitions which
through it we got to know Saudi residents
who had artwork such as photography
cinema and experts in Al- Qatt AL Asiri
that was the first time I’ve ever heard of
and other students’ artwork out of border
and they tried to develop their capacities
,eventually we’d a great artistic database
we knew new colleagues and
.we pleased to know them
Then we moved to organize steps
managed by attaché exhibitions
that had participants from exhibitions
,or candidates among of graduates and jobs
we connected to nonprofit cultural
associations as entrepreneur ambassadors
We organized galleries and joined
,to deliver Kingdom’s sight of 2030
as for me in health sector I had come
to the ministry of health since
we joined in making the
gallery in Bermingham
the moved from Bermingham
to Edinburgh there
there’d been great interaction from
British citizens as it their first time
Saudi culture through art, paintings
photos and cinema that we showed there.
Then, the General Tourism authority sent
us asking for organizing tourism fair
travel, being residentials Saudi speakers,
means English language is local,
with whom we help to guide
for knowing the Kingdom there
It was a rich experience. The question
that always comes to mind
when will you open tourism? from voyagers
that say I have traveled the world
I’ve never travelled Saudi
when will you open tourism
.I had not had an answer
Then we worked on cultural days
during the Crown Prince’s visit to the UK
We cooperated with Misk and
the Culture Authority at a time of
cultural exhibition, and the attendance
were interested on Saudi art and culture
During this exhibition, we also got
to know a group of colleagues
who said why don’t we
start the same affair
The cultural idea of “soft-power” in UK
Then we participated in the
,Tolerance Exhibition, which in Islam
which was sponsored by the
.Association of Islamic world
I presented the conference at the time
I was honored to present and also
in dialogue with the attendees
from all of sects and religions
What do you know about all religions
.of Saudi Arabia? They only knew simple
things can you talk to us
?can you travel without a mahram
that were all the questions always jump in
minds but when gathered with Saudi
learners’ who well educated and displayed
country well, they actually found
people are against what they don’t know
.they were know only what the press shows
The media was a little pressured
on us in Saudi Arabia
that since, I called acquaintances during
scholarship told them what we should do
This mobile platform is only interested
in Saudi culture, run by Saudis and others
another thing, that represents Saudi
artists in more than region
We agreed to start something called
Saudi signatures or signatures
.Saudi signatures are Saudi phrase or noun
It started with bearing a signature on
a panel at the end of a movie, on photo
for a transfer. It’s an artist’s imprint
so, he represents his country and himself.
We started to make exhibitions’ group
in which achieved more than 25 exhibitions
In cooperation with universities
from the largest British universities
we have reached the largest segment
we can imagine from candidates
certainly, all universities contain
a huge segment of candidates
Many of the faculty members
of university students who are
interested in art attended the
exhibition, the kingdom is from our eyes
How do we see our country? It was so fancy
We desired to go to Islamic centers, too
Those who asked we need Kingdom’s photos
of Two Holy Mosques of anything
you can offer in Ramadan or Eid Al-fitter
In fact, we joined them in the Islamic
.Center for organizing some exhibitions
These exhibitions were to
convey a big breakthrough for
the name of signatures in the
Kingdom and the visits that were
from the House of Lords said I am a Muslim
and I visited Saudi Arabia seven times
but I’ve not seen what you just
displayed all were new things
my next trip would be in a large border
within Kingdom of Saudia Arabia
This was a kind of appreciation after
we received many honors from the attaché
Universities, government institutions
even colleagues was great praise
of honor winning Moderation prize as the
best volunteer initiative to serve Kingdom
since abroad, another term
we won extra balancing prize
as the best voluntary initiative
,Another term, after finished
we wondered to stop
or continue since, I ended my task, back
home I handed over to mates, how to gist
The materialistic is great, the technical
weight is great that you run a
scientific institution or cultural and
continue how to guarantee the continuing
Of course, we have registered as
.a non-profit organization in Britain
,This can at least ensure sustainability
ensure legitimacy and credibility
Members’ signatures were among the elite
artists specializing in art scholarship in
Cinema scholarship in fine art have
strong people in their specialization
each of them was a leader
,that represents their region
If we needed, we could do an exhibition
as, in Reed or in any other city.
The same person runs everything, as we’re
members attend as guests each as a leader
each was raised and specialized so, when
back home was never afraid knowing they’ll
keep their job in which term they changed
members and got American fellowship
since that, I was without a travel team
first thing I looked paintings and brushes
I wouldn’t do so in Britain that was huge
effort, and couldn’t do further
, then i got a call from undersecretary
for mission affairs, said: you do amazing
in Britain you should continue in America
Take this torch, there’re people don’t
know Britain, which is close to the Arabs
in culture indeed we needed, that was
huge responsibility I hesitated to handle
in which I manage on my own, and I’ve not
team, truly I can serve my country by art
but throughout knowledge as well has its
weight, loved to focus though convinced me
saying they’re volunteers from candidate
clubs could help us indeed happened there
then, we created exhibitions after 2 weeks
of arrival, got a call from Saudi ministry
We’ve a DC Passport exhibition, which
is an exhibition where embassies
open their doors to all visitors to know
other related culture of that embassies
they asked what kind of
?business do you have
They said photos should be sent directly
I did so, and attended in weekend
the exhibition was pretty nice, and i
was proud of it, we collected a number of
which helped us in collecting
other Saudi art creations
which some of weren’t able to, I shipped
mine in America, all I left at the attaché
after i came back to Boston, I
found a lot pf calls from scholars
they want their creations for
sultan of candidate clubs group
which in order to contact with me
I was just a coordinator, and the attaché
sends them our work we succeed
in more than exhibition in Britain streets
through volunteers who have directors
in art and I’ve not professional technical
team, but those scholars appreciate
their country and proud of their
creations, which exemplified their
signatures only
throughout their existed creations here
all we did, we were managers who honored
a lot of visits as mayor of the city
of Newcastle, and its exhibition, also
mayor of Sawan city university
Swansea gallery was visited by lot of
consular officials of embassies from
foreign fine artists who attended with us
galleries that have huge fact and impact
I don’t consider it as an individual go
from interested people who love art
we are ambitious for spreading
more what I learnt from this experience
or what volunteering taught me, is that
you need not word to contact the globe
the board of an artwork within senses
barriers the words to be spoken
We were ready to display business
at any time, business ready
In an organized manner, so that it’s
displayed anywhere and in any forum
Volunteering is fueled by giving. We all
love art and love the kingdom, so
this was fuel for us to continue, despite
harsh affairs, as moving creations
fund and support all were the most
beautiful things that voluntary gave
in which were challenges in
scientific path and art path
as well for everyone wants to be noticed
by their knowledge and culture
all these faded, or let’s say the
?obsession was how to present the Kingdom
that time was lot of critics on
us indeed what happened
all faded challenges, ambitions
people die, and achievements vanish
But the homeland remains, and the
soil of the homeland we are from, and
we return to it, Allah willing
I am thankful